good morning
sorry to keep waiting
i've just spoken for some time with
president
ukraine
i told him as i have each every time we
spoke at the united states the people of
ukraine and they're bravely as they
fight to defend their country and they
are doing that
and as food continues as merciless
assault the united states and our allies
and partners continue to work in
lockstep
to ramp up the economic pressures on
putin and defer isolate russia in a
global state
later today together with other nato
allies g7 canada
france germany italy japan
the united kingdom as well as the
european union we're going to join them
now to several new steps to squeeze
proof
and hold more even more accountable for
his aggression against ukraine
i want to speak to a few of those points
today
first
each of our nation is going to take
steps to deny the most favored nation
status
to
russia
our most favored nation's status in the
nation
means two countries
have agreed to trade with each other
under the best possible terms
low tariffs few barriers trade and the
highest possible imports allowed
in the united states we call this
permanent normal trade relations pmtr
it's the same thing
revoking pntr for russia it's going to
make it harder for russia to do business
with the united states
and doing it in this election
to make up half of the global economy
will be another crushing globe to the
aggression of congress already suffering
very badly from our sanctions
i want to thank speaker pelosi leader
mccarthy leader schumer and mcconnell
and senators widening credible
representative neil and brady for their
bipartisan leadership on this and the
congress
i would like to offer a special thanks
to speaker quotes who's been a strong
advocate for
revoking pntr and who agreed to hold off
on that in the house until i could line
up all of our key allies to keep us in
complete unison unity among our allies
is critically important as you all know
from my perspective
but standing for democracy in ukraine
pushing russia's aggression
should not be one of those issues a free
world is coming together to confront
putin
our two parties here at home are leading
the way
with that bipartisan cooperation i'm
looking forward to signing the law the
bill revoking pntr
which is again most people think of his
most favorite nation
status
we're also taking the first step into
goods several signature sectors
between seafood and diamonds
we're going to continue to squeeze from
the g7 will seek to deny russia the
ability to borrow from leading
multinational institutions such as the
international monetary fund and the
world bank
is an aggressor
is the aggressor and putin must pay the
price
he cannot pursue a war that threatens
the very foundations which he's doing
the very foundation of international
peace and stability and then asked for
financial help from the international
community
the g7 is also stepping up pressure
on corrupt russian billionaires we're
adding new names to the list of
oligarchs and their families that we're
targeting and we're increasing
coordination among the g7 countries to
target and capture their ill-forgotten
gains
they support putin they steal from the
russian people
and they seek to hide the money in our
countries
they're part of that kleptocracy that
exists in moscow they must share the
pain
of these sanctions
and
while we're going after these uh
vacation homes for hundreds of million
dollars we're also going to make it
harder for them to buy high-end products
manufactured in our country
advancing the export of
luxury goods to russia
they're also the latest steps we're
taking but
they're not the last
as i said at the beginning of all these
steps we're going to have proven harder
because the united states and our
closest allies and partners are acting
in unison
the totality of our citizens united
border control is crushing the russian
economy
ruble has lost more than half its value
they tell me it takes about
200 rubles
moscow stock exchange has been closed
for fully for two weeks because they
know the moment opens it will probably
collapse
creating the agency has downgraded
russia's government to junk status
its economy to junk status
a list of businesses international
corporations leaving russia is growing
by the day
we're also continuing to close
corporations with allies and partners to
make sure that there's close cooperation
we continue to have ukrainian people are
are able to defend their own nation
the united states has set more than one
billion dollars in security systems
ukraine over the last year
including
anti-armor and anti-air capabilities
taking out tanks and planes and
helicopters
with new shipments arriving every day
we in the united states are also
facilitating significant shipments of
security assistance from our allies and
partners to ukraine
and the humanitarian front we're working
closely with and humanitarian
organizations to support the people of
ukraine and displaced by the violence
providing for providing tens of
thousands of tons of human supply
from humanitarian supplies
food water and medicines coming by a
truck and train every single day
yesterday in poland vice president
harrison has announced an additional 53
million
in additional humanitarian support
that brings the total humanitarian
assistance to 107 million dollars in
just two weeks
we've joined this effort
by moore with more than 30 other
countries for providing hundreds of
millions more
and last night a great credit to
congress passed the bipartisan spending
bill
and included an additional 13.6
billion dollars
i look forward to signing that
immediately i also want to be clear
though we will make sure ukraine has
weapons to defend against an invading
russian force
we will
send money food and aid to save the
ukrainian people
and i will welcome ukrainian refugees we
should welcome them here with open arms
and need access
and we're going to provide more support
from ukraine
we're going to continue to stand
together with our allies in europe and
send unmistakable messages will defend
every single inch of nato territory of
the full might of the united and
galvanized nato
we will not fight a war against russia
in ukraine
direct confrontation between nato and
russia is world war iii
something we must describe
but we already know whose war against
ukraine will never be victory
he hoped to dominate ukraine without a
fight he failed helped to fracture
european resolve he failed helped to
weaken the transatlantic alliance he
failed helped to split apart american
democracies in terms of our positions he
failed
the american people are united the world
is united and we stand with the people
of ukraine we will not let autocrats and
would-be emperors dictate the direction
of the world
democracies are rising to meet this
moment
rallying the world to the side of peace
and the side of security
we're showing our strength and we will
not falter
god bless all of you god bless ukraine
and god bless our troops
president biden president biden your
white house has said that that russia
may use chemical weapons or create a
false flag operation to use them what
evidence have you seen showing that and
would the u.s have a military response
if putin does launch a chemical weapons
attack i'm not going to speak about the
intelligence but but russia would pay a
severe
make pretty soft price